Chief Justice John Roberts must now come
forward and and state if he allows and
is allowing this kind of very serious
corruption to happen on the on this
court I think you know when it comes to
to Justice uh Thomas's statement when
he's talking about his colleagues and
when he's talking about who advised him
to break the law I think we need to know
who those people are now of course we
run into the reality that Republicans
control the House of Representatives and
there's basically no world in which
Kevin McCarthy decides to introduce
articles of impeachment against Clarence
Thomas at least not over this issue but
I do believe it's good that there are
calls for him to face an Ethics
violation calls for him to step down and
this call for him to be impeached